I've got some fantastic video for you.
That reminds me of a very interesting David
Pakman show viral clip from years ago.
What happened over the last few days is that
vice president Mike Pence showed up at a diner
in Des Moines, Iowa called the Drake diner.
He stumbled upon a table where an emergency
room doctor confronted Mike Pence about the
Trump administration's policy on a bunch of
things related to healthcare.
And Mike Pence malfunction is the only way
I can describe it.
He froze up.
He didn't know the Trump administration policy.
He tried to change the subject and then he
threw in just standard propaganda, disinformation
phrases that are used strategically to stop
having to actually know anything.
Uh, so this reminded me of the clip that we
did a years ago called Mitt Romney gets his
ass handed to him by a gay veteran, which
now has nearly a million views and it's a
similar setup where at the time at Romney
was running for president.
He showed up at some restaurant in New Hampshire
and he approached a guy and it turned out
that the guy was a gay veteran who confronted
Romney on a whole bunch of issues and it was
fantastic.
So back to this year and the Drake diner in
Des Moines, Iowa.
This is going to be sort of another one of
these propaganda disinformation breakdown
type videos featuring dr Rob Davidson, dr
Rob Davidson's and emergency room doctor Mike
Pence walks in, walks up to Dr. Davidson,
shakes hands and it very quickly goes South
and you will see Mike Pence instantly regretting
this.
Like the second Dr. Davidson starts talking
Pence is not pleased.
We're going to listen to a few seconds and
then notice that when Dr. Davidson says, these
are the things you're doing now that are bad.
Penn says, you know, when I was governor here
or we didX , Y, andZ , that has nothing to
do with Trump administration policy, which
is what Dr. Davidson is trying to talk about.
So this is the first disinflation technique.
Let's take a look.
Hey gentlemen.
Hey, you're out.
Davidson.
He done.
Good to meet you.
I'm Joel Joel.
So I've by the emergency doctor, I'm worried
about plans.
They talked about last week of maybe cutting
Medicare and then the roll out today of cutting
Medicaid.
I work in working with one of the poorest
counties in Michigan and my patients depend
on expanded Medicaid.
So how is that going to affect my patients?
You know, uh, cut Medicaid.
Yeah, the, uh, the CMS announced the, uh,
the plan to let Sage file waiters so they
could get block grants.
So that would essentially cut the amount of
money going into the States.
So they would cut federal Medicaid funding.
Is that a good idea?
Actually, uh, when I was governor of Louisiana,
we got a waiver from your bond to expand Medicaid
coverage to the States.
So Dr. Davidson is talking about right now,
and Mike Pence is talking about, well, you
know, when I was governor in Indiana, we did
this, that, or the other thing.
So let's now back it up a few seconds.
We're going to pick it back up and the good
doctor does not let Mike Pence get away with
it and says, I'm talking about now I'm not
talking about when you were governor, I'm
talking about national policy now that you're
the vice president.
So Dr. Davidson tries it a second time, take
a look
to expand that coverage, right?
But now they're talking about scaling back
the Medicaid expansion that they, that we
got with the affordable care act.
And that 680,000 Michigan are 600,000 and
a lot of people got health.
We expanded coverage in Indiana.
Let's talk about the president and your administration
right now.
What they're doing right now, they're cutting
waivers for States that didn't take expansion
for people, took expansion money to.
So Mike Pence again tries to talk about who
knows what year he's even referring to and
Dr. Davidson brings him back.
The reality is just that Mike Pence doesn't
know the policy right now.
He has no idea what Dr. Davidson is talking
about.
And here's how the conversation ultimately
wrapped up with another technique which we'll
point out.
Do you mean your administration just analysis,
they rolled it out today and it's gonna affect
millions of people across the country cutting
Medicaid.
I mean, is that a good idea or is that bad
cure over simplified?
I think it comes down to that for the people
I take care of all the time.
I mean, people I see in the emergency department
that can't get primary care doctors, you know,
once they get Medicaid, they can get primary
care doctors, they stay out of the ER, they
actually work more.
They actually contributed to our community
more.
Now, if we, couple of people, sorry, you don't
get your healthcare.
I mean that's going to be a real negative
in their eyes.
This
actually by coincidence, ends up being a good
example of how to detect BS and disinformation
techniques.
So let's go through it.
Mike Pence first gets confronted with some
facts and he doesn't really seem to know the
facts or he certainly can't defend what his
administration has been doing.
So he changes the subject.
Dr Davidson's talking about one thing, 2020
national healthcare policy, and Mike Penn
starts talking about some year when he was
a Indiana governor, uh, policy, uh, specifically
in Indiana.
And that's not what a Dr. Davidson is trying
to talk about.
It may or may not be true what Penn's is saying,
but it's certainly not what's being discussed
right now.
Then Pence changes tactic and he misstates
the current policy.
So he says, well, you know, it's waivers or
this or that.
And Dr. Davidson again, says, no, calls him
out.
Doesn't let them get away with that.
So then Mike Pence does a wrap up that's similar
to let's agree to disagree.
Now sometimes it's logical to say, let's agree
to disagree.
Sometimes in a conversation with family or
friends, you're just, you're not going to
get anywhere else.
You're not making policy decisions, you just
say, let's agree to disagree.
When an elected official like Mike Pence uses
that, uh, uh, or, or something similar to
it, it's a sign that they're losing.
And what Mike Penn said was, I think you were
over-simplifying.
That's a conversation ender similar to let's
agree to disagree, maybe actually more pernicious
and again, nice job by dr Rob Davidson and
that lets me get to the fourth tactic.
Dr. Davidson in a sense, has a horse in this
race.
Okay.
And some people after this video went viral,
found out, although it's not a secret that
Dr. Davidson is involved with an organization
or an organization called the committee to
protect Medicare.
So the fourth, this information tactic, Mike
Pence did three of them.
Number four is actually being done by right
wingers who just want to attack Dr. Davidson.
If you look on the internet, the fourth tactic
is this.
Dr. Davidson dude is biased.
He's part of a group that wants to protect
Medicare.
Strictly speaking, that's an ad hominem, right?
Like, yeah, of course this guy has an opinion
and Mike Pence has an opinion.
Dr. Davidson is on a committee to protect
Medicare.
That doesn't change the fact that Dr. Davidson
is asserting.
Mike Pence also has a horse in the race in
that his administration, he is Trump's vice
president.
They have policy that they want to convince
people is good policy.
So it's an ad hominem.
Strictly speaking to say you can't believe
Davidson because he's on a committee that
wants to protect Medicare.
You know, there's a lot of senior citizens
who also want to protect Medicare.
Are we going to call them all biased in the
exact same way where we say the facts don't
matter?
No.
You can have an opinion and the facts still
matter.
That is a disinflation technique number four,
which is discount the position as irrelevant
or not believable because the person is biased
by having a horse in the race.
You can bet your ass that Mike Pence has a
horse in the race, which is, he doesn't want
Donald Trump's policy to look like the, the,
the, you know what hitting the fan that it
is actually been.